cobra kai might be all about the karate
wars but it has more in common with body
slams and suplexes than anyone could
have imagined one of the most monumental
terry silver scenes in cobra kai season
4 is his rootless deal with rejected
kobrikai student stingray after silver
beats stingray up and sets up john
crease to take the fall the millionaire
alone is in control of the cobra kai
dojo in season 5 we find out that
stingray received bragging rights terry
enforced cobra kai respect and a sweet
material compensation for his role in
the betrayal as the season proceeds it
becomes clear that stingray's cool new
crib and even cooler new ride haven't
been able to extinguish the burning
shame that hides underneath his
confrontational demeanor kris might be
in prison but he's intent on proving
that he's innocent and as always he
isn't above using underhanded tactics to
achieve his goals knowing that daniel
larusso and his allies wouldn't give him
the time of day if he contacted them
crease unless tory nichols to give
daniel a nameless tip about the
situation desperate to get a win over
terry daniel decides to pay stingray a
visit when the controversial kobrakai
student eventually makes an appearance
he's behind the wheel of the cool cobra
kai dodge challenger that used to belong
to johnny rocking out to judas by fozzie
the hard rocking song about becoming a
judas is an extremely good fit for the
traitorous character who blasted on full
volume and sings along to the lyrics
however as it so often does cobra kai
adds some seriously dark undercurrents
and deeper meanings in this deceptively
simple scene in fact stingray's new
theme song just so happens to mean much
more than you'd initially assume and
alludes to his rise and fall in the
series having the show's biggest judas
character rocking out to a song called
judas is pretty obvious but there is a
twist the judas and the song's lyrics is
absolutely horrified of what he's done
and hopes to find a way to write his
wrongs this telegraph stingrays deep
regret for his actions and his eventual
redemption in the season finale as the
chorus of the song goes what have i
become now that i've betrayed everyone
i've ever loved i pushed them all away
and i have been a slave to the judas in
my mind is there something left of me to
save in the wreckage of my life these
few lines sum up stingray's cobra kai
season 5 arc in an eerily efficient
fashion as he comes to feel the exact
same way about his actions don't think
that the song's hidden meaning ends
there though the singer of fozzie is
none other than chris jericho the famed
pro wrestler who works with all elite
wrestling and uses judas as his entrance
theme this isn't jericho's first time in
the cobra kai limelight the man himself
has thanked the show for a name drop in
season 3 episode 6. jericho also seems
to be on good terms with martin cove the
actor has appeared as a guest on
jericho's this is jericho podcast and
he's also turned up on aew dynamite as
wrestler dr britt baker sensei the
lighter moments of cobra kai and
professional wrestling scratch a pretty
similar itch so they seem like a pretty
natural match since cobra kai's season 5
only strengthens jericho's ties to the
show it could be just a matter of time
before the hard rocking wrestler appears
on the show in the flesh perhaps he
could turn up his arrival sensei in the
grand tournament of the hopefully
inevitable cobra kai season 6.
[Applause]
[Music]